when I'm drawing it's one of the rare
times where I'm kind of focused and and
feel like the world slows down
I'm Joel Crawford the director of Puss
and Boots Last Wish hi I'm Domi she the
director and co-writer of turning red
I'm Chris Williams I'm the writer and
director of the Sea Beast my name is Jon
Rosales I'm the director animator writer
and composer of ice merchants and today
I'm going to be drawing my characters
receiving an Oscar and today I'm going
to draw Jacob Holland winning an Oscar
and today I'm going to be drawing Puss
and Boots receiving an Oscar I will be
drawing my character melon Lee receiving
an Oscar my definitive drawing point
would be like the head the Tilt the
angle and kind of like the expression of
the character I find it's usually good
to start with the cranium figure out
that line of action through the middle
of the character what I love about Puss
in Boots is that there's this Charisma
but Underneath It All he's a cat that's
wearing boots maybe the light that's
reflecting off of the Oscar creating
kind of like a laser pointer effect
would totally distract Puss in Boots and
he can't help but cat like chase after
it so with these characters for me the
most important part art was really to
emphasize the father-son relationship
that's why I believe I also choose to
exaggerate their precautions for example
the father having very very long legs
and keep it being quite small it was
very important for me to establish that
very nice relationship they have going
it was a challenge for us especially in
this movie because a lot of things that
are associated with being a tween girl
are very expensive and complicated to do
backpacks are incredibly difficult and
expensive to simulate her Tamagotchi on
her backpack I definitely fought for
that Tamagotchi one of the things we
really wanted to land with with Jacob as
a character is that he's a really
good-hearted guy alright so there's my
under drawing so now I'll go ahead
and do the ink drawing the eyes are so
important they're so expressive and cats
have that kind of way where when they're
focused on something they kind of get
this like tunnel vision and it's fun
creating that in like an animated
character this is probably my favorite
phase of the drawing which is when I'm
adding Shadows not only because I like
how they look aesthetically but they're
also perfect to cover some mistakes that
I've done sometimes when I'm drawing a
character's expression I I can't help
but like try to make it myself they're
all giggling at the Oscar's butt that's
the idea for for this drawing and one of
the things that I love about animation
is How Deeply collaborative it is
hundreds of people working for years on
this one thing so excited about the
Oscar that he's leaping forward
I'm just noodling okay I'm done
I drew Jacob Holland one of the main
characters from The Sea Beast holding an
Oscar so he's quite happy with it this
image was what I came to my my Monday
was father holding his son and the son
holding the Husker so it is it's a
double victory for him Malin would be
over the moon she would be so excited to
be holding that heavy naked gold man she
would have poofed into a panda out of
excitement over 400 people worked on
this movie and that means so much that
it's being appreciated not just out in
the world in theaters but also by the
academy
so thank you
[Music]